inside tatiana ali's gorgeous beverly
hills wedding thank you to everybody for
all of your wishes it means the world to
the 37 year old actress married her
boyfriend of almost two years dr. Vaughn
raspberry at the Four Seasons Beverly
Hills on Sunday and et has the exclusive
photos from inside their big day even
more extravagant and more brilliant
Tatiana walked down the aisle with her
father in a gorgeous on solid gone with
floral embellishments paired with drop
earrings a beautiful veil and a bouquet
full of white peonies while the groom
stunned in a custom Octavius Terry tux
and bowtie her bridesmaids all wore
maroon knee-length dresses also by ohm
saleh the glowing bride also had a
reunion of sorts her former Fresh Prince
of bel-air family Alfonso Ribeiro karyn
Parsons and Joseph Marcel were all in
attendance
Tatiana's wedding planner Michael Russo
opened up to eat see about the event
decor explaining it was quote inspired
by Tatiana's Caribbean family history
lots of bright yellow and blue flowers
with touches of lush tropical greens ET
broke the news of the couple's
engagement and pregnancy back in April
the two met through online dating I got
very lucky